durante un parto vaginal la primera
etapa del trabajo de parto dura de 12 a
19 horas y se inicia cuando su bebé Se
mueve hacia su pelvis y se coloca ahí
como respuesta el cuello uterino se
empieza a borrar o volverse más delgado
y dilatar o ensanchar
Durante este proceso usted puede sentir
contracciones fuertes y regulares que
ocurren cada 5 a 20 minutos además de
dolor lumbar y cólicos que no
desaparecen es posible que vea un flujo
mucoso amarronado o rojizo el cual puede
ser el tapón mucoso que se desprende de
la abertura de su cuello uterino su saco
amniótico puede romperse el cual puede
ser abundante chorro de agua o un goteo
continuo si experimenta alguno de estos
síntomas comuníquese con su médico o
partera para saber si debe ir al
hospital